so you're the creator of coca-cola in
the late 1800s more specifically your
name is john pemberton an ex-soldier in
the american civil war
injured in battle you develop a
crippling morphine addiction
and after decades of poverty and illness
you finally decided to find a cure and
started a business in 1884 so logically
the best way to cure your addiction and
become rich is by using cocaine
cocoa was the most interesting actually
because i thought
you know it's called
coca-cola so does it have cocaine in it
um and so i went back to look at that
and turns out yeah you know trace
amounts back still in the beginning you
see in 19th century america cocaine and
the coca leaves it was made from were
not illegal they were actually pretty
popular in the late 1800s coca leaves
and cocaine were seen as medicinal and
everyone was using it and one man named
angelo mariani was making a fortune from
it he made a cocoa wine called vin
moriyani which was basically red wine
mixed with insane amount of coca queen
victoria president ulysses s grant
thomas edison and even two popes were
raising fans of this cocoa wine
soyu a broke war veteran pharmacist
decided that the best way to make money
is to create a knockoff of an already
popular product you wouldn't have to do
any of the marketing yourself because
then mariani had already done the work
for you and plus regular people couldn't
really afford the cocoa wine that elites
were drinking so you launched your own
version of it pemberton's french wine
coca nerve tonic it was a near exact
imitation of ben mariani it still had
the coca in it except for one other
thing cola nuts which contain caffeine
and in your opinion it set your product
apart from the rest
so you started selling and you marketed
your french cocoa one as the end all be
all it could cure opiate addiction upset
stomachs headaches and other health
problems there was nothing this miracle
cocaine infused tonic couldn't do
according to you of course
but then prohibition hit georgia
[Music]
and by 1886 most alcohol production and
sales came to a standstill in the states
which meant no one was allowed to buy
your new and very popular products
because of the alcohol not the cocoa
but interestingly the reason that
cocaine became taboo and why it got
pulled from the drink had nothing to do
with national laws in the country which
was so interesting when i was studying
it it had everything to do with
racism actually in the south because
there was a concern that
cocaine was contributing to black crime
in atlanta but instead of just giving up
you simply change up the marketing for
the products took out the alcohol kept
the coca added carbonated water and
added a lot of sugar like over five
pounds of sugar per gallon of syrup what
started as a cocoa wine became a cocoa
and cola nut syrup not a full-blown soda
like we know today just yet and boom
coca-cola was born
marketed as the temperance drink the
temperance movement was a term used for
the anti-alcohol crowd your new
coca-cola syrup could be sold to
pharmacies who then mixed it with
carbonated water before serving since
cola nuts contain caffeine it served to
only make the drink even more popular
and addictive and not only did switching
to water save your product from being
banned it made it a whole lot cheaper
and more accessible to the everyday kind
of person the average worker would get
off a long day of back-breaking work and
head to their local pharmacy for a cold
drink during these local alcohol bans
pharmacies were the new politically
correct bars
unfortunately for you not everyone liked
this new coca-cola beverage it reminded
them of the good old days when alcohol
was still around so in your first year
you only sold 600 gallons of syrup sure
it was a good start but it was nowhere
near enough to repay the investments
people made into your business and in
1887 you were right back to where you
started looking for a way to make your
new coca-flavored drink profitable but
then you die
no seriously john peppertin died on
august 16 1888 before he could see his
drink become one of america's greatest
success stories
a drug addict as a founder a failing
syrup business and a company on the
verge of bankruptcy that was coca-cola
near the end of the 1800s so how did a
failing company with a morphine-addicted
owner become one of the biggest most
profitable businesses in the world worth
more than 87 billion dollars and
employing over 700 000 people
the history of coca-cola only gets
stranger from
here million times a day
at home at work or on the way there's
nothing like a coca cola nothing like a
coke
one of coca-cola's biggest marketing
tactics are video ads i'm sure you've
seen at least one ad for coke on tv or
youtube the problem is making
professional videos is pretty difficult
and expensive you need stock video
footage pictures music sound effects
animations the list just keeps going on
and on but what if there was one place
where you could instantly download all
those assets for one single affordable
subscription well that's where
storyblocks comes in today's video
sponsor unlike other sites storyblocks
doesn't make you pay per video or assets
instead you pay one affordable
subscription every month for unlimited
downloads of everything you might need
to make pro level edits like this
[Music]
and if you're new to video editing
storyblocks even has an easy intuitive
video editor that's included in your
subscription it lets you easily add
storyblocks content directly into your
project and lets you export your video
into all the popular formats and they
even have customizable templates for you
to start out with so if you're looking
to make great videos for your business
or personal brand you can get started by
going to
storyblocks.comtrain right now to sign
up for their unlimited all-access plan
there's no commitment and you can cancel
whenever you want that's storyblocks.com
has jtam with the link below
[Music]
john pemberton's morphine addiction
eventually killed him in 1888.
apparently mixing morphine and coca
together was not all that good for your
health but before he died a man named
asa candler bought a controlling stake
in coca-cola for around three thousand
dollars or around 86 thousand dollars in
today's money by 1891 candler was a sole
proprietor as asa candler you had a
difficult road ahead of you marketing
and growing the business wasn't going to
be easy but luckily you were the man to
do it with a near perfect recipe created
by pemberton all you had to do was focus
on marketing but this was the 1800s no
one knew what coca-cola was and there
weren't any tvs or social media
influencers to promote your products so
you had to do it the old-fashioned way
and to do that you spent thousands of
dollars plastering the new coca-cola
logo on anything the company could get
its hands on suddenly the logo was
printed painted and stamped on
everything from wallets to barn walls
and coca-cola wall calendars in atlanta
georgia you couldn't walk down the
street without staring down at least one
coca-cola ad but that just wasn't enough
to boost sales advertising just couldn't
make up for the fact that there were
hundreds of different syrups on the
market and no one knew what yours tasted
like
so you came up with a better idea free
samples
as the owner of coca-cola you contacted
every major pharmacy in the area and
asked them for the names of their top 50
customers an early form of buying leads
then you sent each of those customers a
coupon for a free glass of coca-cola
like today people in the 19th century
also loved getting free stuff and you
knew that if they could just taste how
deliciously addictive your new drink was
they would be customers for life and you
were right within less than a decade
coca-cola was selling a quarter of a
million gallons of syrup a year but then
just like the prohibition on alcohol in
the early 1900s cocaine and coca leaves
were now the targets
[Music]
everybody's happy when you bring home
the cockatoo
that real great taste leaves you so
refreshed
coca-cola put you at your sparkling best
legal use of cocaine increased by 700
between 1890 and 1902 by 1901 1.8
million pounds of cocales were imported
into the us people were literally going
crazy for the stuff but then just a year
later the government started turning
against cocaine and coca the problem was
that by 1898 alone coca-cola was already
eating up more than 59 000 pounds of
cocoa leaves to produce the syrup and it
was only going up from there in 1902
georgia banned cocaine distribution and
a lot of other states followed their
example then in 1903 the new york times
published an expose that linked cocaine
to an increase in crime in the racially
fueled south stories of african
americans becoming criminals because
they used cocaine were the talk of the
town so you asa candler a devout
christian decided to do what's best for
your conscience and obviously your
business and remove the coca from the
coca-cola formula the only problem was
removing cocoa from the syrup would
completely change the taste of the drink
facing a corporate disaster you found a
way to preserve the taste it was so
famous for decoconized coca leaves or
coca leaf extract that didn't have the
cocaine in it this new cocaine-free coca
extract became part of what the company
calls merchandise number five one of the
codes used to describe the company's
secret formula that was made to
intentionally sound vague and unassuming
the new band on cocaine meant that only
two companies in the us were allowed to
import and process coca leaves mark of
raw way and maywood chemical works in
new jersey in other words the u.s has
granted a monopoly on coca leaves to
just two companies
because of this coca-cola became
completely reliant on maywood to make
their new decoconized extract but by the
1920s the trade and coca had become so
restrictive that you questioned your
company's future by the 1920s coca-cola
had become a massive corporation and a
big part of american culture it was
everywhere and they had a lot of money
at their disposal so you did what any
other million dollar company does when
the government comes knocking you bribe
them so they go away also known as
lobbying led by the national association
of retail druggists your lobbying
campaign succeeded section 6 of
something called the harrison narcotics
tax act was created which regulated
opiate and coca products and section 6
allowed the use of decoconized coca
leaves and any other form of coca that
doesn't contain cocaine to be used in
products and since your company was the
only one that actually used coca for
flavor section 6 eventually got the
nickname coca-cola joker
officials may have said that they did it
to allow trade and economic growth but
deep down everyone knew there was no way
you were going to go up against the
corporate giant that is coca-cola
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're free reign to use as much coca as
you want you ran into the next problem
supply the maywood chemical company just
couldn't keep up with your demands for
more than 200 000 pounds of coca leaves
every year so like any good businessman
you started looking at your options and
in 1928 coca-cola and maywood started a
coca extraction plant in peru it
produced 4 000 pounds of coca extract
and 18 kilograms of pure cocaine and
since cocaine sales weren't illegal
outside of america those 18 kilos were
sold for a thousand dollars yes
coca-cola and maywood were literally
selling cocaine not coca leaves outside
of the us but then the state department
got involved and threatened to take away
mei was licensed to import coca legally
and the plan was abandoned after the
failed attempt of making coca extract
outside the us you finally got what you
wanted in the first place an increase in
how much coca meiwka imports the 1930
porter act increased the limit on how
many special leaves used in
coca-flavored drinks could be imported
but coke needed actually so much
flavoring there's a special exemption in
our laws for what are called special
leaves
from peru and they're special because
they're allowed to come into the united
states exclusively basically to create
the flavoring extract for coca-cola and
you were back on track suddenly maywood
had access to so much cocoa that they
plan on selling the extract to other
companies as well now this was a major
problem coca made your drink special it
was something that you had and no one
else could get their hands on if other
companies started making cocoa flavored
drinks you would lose business your
competitive edge would be at stake so
you threatened maywood that if they ever
sell koka to anyone else you would drop
their business entirely and it worked
mae would agree to stick to your terms
and since they had a legal monopoly on
the import of coca and you were their
only customer coca-cola effectively
cemented its monopoly on coca-flavored
drinks
basically coke has this exclusive right
to bring in coca-leaves into the united
states this is what pepsi we were
talking about pepsi earlier
they wanted access it's one of the
reasons why coke you know they have a
unique flavor right they have something
that no one else can get well if
everyone had access to coca leaves you
know the price of coca leaves might be
pretty high because they only have
access to that leaf they get a great
deal on the price of coca leaves because
of international laws that ban it by the
way that we're in part brokered by
coca-cola by now coca-cola was a
globally recognized brand but overseas
operations were nothing compared to what
you sold in the us and that all changed
when world war ii hits
[Music]
when world war ii came along you saw the
opportunity to expand like never before
if you could show that coca-cola was a
patriot that koch supported the troops
in their fight against evil you could
win the hearts of the american public
like never before so you joined the war
efforts as the chairman of coke you went
to the government and promised to give
every single soldier a cold bottle of
coca-cola for just 5 cents now at 5
cents a bottle you take a loss on every
bottle sold however if a soldier goes
through the toughest battles of his life
he goes through hell and back he gets
back to his base he's exhausted and he
just wants to wind down and take his
mind off of things and you're there to
serve him a delicious there's quenching
drink at a steep discount to boost his
morale do you honestly think he's ever
gonna buy any other soda when he gets
back home for himself his family or his
friends not a chance
and it worked when soldiers were asked
what three things could boost their
morale they said cigarettes candy and
coca-cola
when eisenhower went to the troops and
said what can we do to boost morale and
to get you through the war they asked
for three things they asked for
cigarettes they asked for candy and they
asked for coca-cola president eisenhower
even wrote to you asking to set up
mobile bottling plants in europe in 1944
alone coke made 25 million dollars in
profits from selling under a military
contract and wherever soldiers went
coca-cola was the perfect drink to share
with the locals so effectively the us
military became your biggest ever sales
force spreading your product all over
the world the drink was so sought after
that even nazi germany wanted coke but
you know selling coca-cola to germany
would be like treason or something and
go against your patriotic brand image so
you invented fanta to sell to the
germans making money off of both sides
of the war while simultaneously sleeping
under the conscience of the american
public
i'm playing both sides so that i always
come out on top by the end of the war
coca-cola sold an estimated 10 billion
bottles of coke to the troops and cope
became as american as it could get but
this massive expansion came with its own
problems
there are times every day as you work or
you play when a pause would be welcome
to you
and it's then that you'll find the
bright thought in your mind that only a
coke
will do
business exploded after world war ii you
had enough coca because of the monopoly
and you had enough sugar because of the
better markets after the war but there
was one last supply problem caffeine
so the cocoa was fun and interesting and
wild but then i got the caffeine and
that's what led to this so like where
does the caffeine come from i tried to
google it as one does and i was like
where's the caffeine come from and i
couldn't figure it out at first using
cola nuts seemed like a good idea but
they grew far away there wasn't enough
and the caffeine in them wasn't really
any different from the caffeine and
things like coffee and tea so without a
steady supply of caffeine your coca-cola
wouldn't have the same energizing kick
so you decide to change your caffeine
source to something cheaper and in
greater supply tea leaves in the 1900s
the world was in a tea drinking craze
westerners all wanted the best highest
quality tea to drink which meant a lot
of damage and broken leaves were being
left to rot in warehouses and what did
all these tea leaves have in common they
all contain caffeine so in 1904 a little
known company that you may have heard of
called monsanto was formed and monsanto
offered coca-cola caffeine made from
these old damaged tea leaves and once
again you were back in action
for coca-cola there would be no monsanto
really yes when monsanto this chemical
company from st louis that started in
1901 it was like barely getting by it
was you know the american chemical
industry almost didn't exist the germans
were really in control they ran the
organic chemistry we were getting all of
our chemicals from overseas and so
they needed a big contract and so their
initial buyer was coca-cola and they
sold coca-cola two things they sold them
saccharin the artificial sweetener which
ultimately comes from coal tar and talk
about that and then
caffeine so basically they took tea
leaves that were broken and damaged
around the world like on tea exchanges
like the garbage of the tea trade and
they realized no one was going to
consume that so it's just waste and they
basically swept that stuff up and
processed out the caffeine from the
garbage from the waste tea tea leaves
that contract with coca-cola would be
the initial boost monsanto needed to set
it on track to become what many consider
one of the most evil corporations in the
world the company responsible for agent
orange pcbs herbicides genetically
modified foods seed licensing and more
but the fact of the matter is that
monsanto is not that different from
other hyper successful companies and
people they're just a lot better at
getting away with extreme stuff see
there are two sides to every hyper
successful person what they tell the
general public about their success it's
all about hard work consistency
perseverance and what they actually
think and do behind closed doors when
the cameras are off
if my competitor were drowning i'd walk
over and i'd put a hose right in his
mouth
the problem is you are never going to
learn any of this unless you are already
in successful circles
why because if the elite didn't hide
this from the public they would be
pillaged and sent to the guillotine or
at the bare minimum they will have more
competition to deal with you're also
never going to learn this from your
friends family or teachers for the same
reason why you're not going to learn how
to lose weight from an overweight person
and you're not going to learn it from
some business professor because again
it's politically incorrect and they're
probably broke that's why i'm starting a
new series called things hidden from the
masses where you're going to learn
everything they will never teach you in
business school and feature length 40
minute plus documentaries every month
and in the first documentary you're
going to learn how the monsanto empire
was built the company that owns the
world's food supply these are going to
be some of the darkest most
machiavellian videos i have ever made
imagine these videos taken to a further
extreme and just like monsanto i also
prefer not to be cancelled so we are not
going to be releasing these to the
public all you have to do if you want to
get this education they will never teach
you in business school is click the join
button below right next to the subscribe
button
and unlike an mba i'm not going to
charge you 55 to 161 thousand dollars to
learn this stuff nope just five dollars
a month for longer documentaries of the
videos you love that you will not be
able to see anywhere else and this five
dollars a month is just to cover the
cost to produce these videos give it a
try for a month and if you don't think
this knowledge is worth it email me and
i will personally refund you the money
so pause the video and click the join
button below right now
so back to coca-cola eventually not even
monsanto could provide enough caffeine
from tea leaves and decaf coffee so you
asked monsanto to do the impossible
create synthetic caffeine and as
expected monsanto came back with a
solution
caffeine made from the chemicals in coal
tar yes actual kotar a byproduct of
processed coal the fossil fuel industry
was booming so naturally there was a lot
of the stuff lying around and sure
people might object to drinking
something with coal tar chemicals in it
so you just keep it vague it seems
logical that their thinking is wait a
minute consumers are never gonna ask
where their caffeine comes from look at
everyone i've never talked to no one
knows where the caffeine comes from
right and if you go to their website
it's great it says we source our
caffeine from tea leaves so that waste
tea leaf story is still part of it
coffee beans
uh decaf coffee and then appropriate
sources appropriate right whichever
as long as coke tastes good nobody will
cure what it's made of and with the
final supply chain problem solved there
was nothing holding coca-cola back from
world domination
[Music]
i'd like to buy the world a home and
furnish it with love
grow up on trees
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2012 coca-cola started selling its
products in burma this meant that there
are only two countries left in the world
that don't sell coke cuba and north
korea researchers working in the south
pole can get an icy coke to enjoy
sub-zero temperatures you can stop for a
coca-cola at the mount everest base camp
and coke even went to space in 1985. in
total around 1.9 million servings of
coke are sold a day that's one in four
people who drink coke at least once a
day
today they have more than 500 brand
names under the coca-cola umbrella and
the company stands as the sixth largest
in the world after brands like apple and
google being valued at over 87 billion
dollars and it all started with a
morphine addictive war veteran that
wanted to rip off a coca-infused one
finely chipped ice
bubbling carbonated water yes people
talked about it tried it and even then
learned the happy enjoyment to be found
in the past that refreshes
so i have to say this is by far one of
my favorite videos i've done so far so
let me know what you guys thought about
it in the comments below as you can see
we are still in the middle of moving
around so excuse the uh poor background
if you're new here we make video essays
documentaries just like this one every
single week for free so if you enjoyed
this one you're definitely going to like
the other ones so click the subscribe
button below and click that join button
below too but that's going to wrap it up
thank you so much for being part of the
watch the end club watching you to the
end is by far the best way to help out
the youtube algorithm so i really
appreciate it keep sharpening that line
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you